you're here today you're announcing uh
the deployment of troops
350 here a thousand on standby russia
has amassed more than a hundred thousand
troops on the border
when you think about those numbers does
it frighten you a bit that actually nato
cannot handle uh what is going on here i
think everybody should be in no doubt
that
were russia to be so foolish to make the
catastrophic mistake of invading any
part of ukraine the ukrainian army
which themselves number about 200 000
maybe 150 000 in reserve they will fight
and there will be uh bloodshed and i
think everybody in russia must
understand that and it will not be easy
what we're doing here today the reason
i'm here today in in poland is showing
our solidarity with our nato partners
and fortifying nato's eastern frontier
so you've got 350 uh troops coming in
from uh four five uh commando here to uh
to help the polls and don't forget don't
forget we've already been giving uh
quite a lot of assistance uh on the
border with uh belarus because of the
aggressive use of of immigration by the
the moscow-supported puppet regime of of
lukashenko and
the importance of this is to to
it's partly to show that we stand
shoulder to shoulder uh with our allies
in in poland which we always do but also
to show that the west as a whole
will strengthen nato's eastern frontiers
rather than uh the reverse and uh
i think putin the kremlin should
understand that if they want
less nato on on their on their western
borders as it were this is entirely the
wrong way to go about it and i need to
bring you back to some domestic issues
what's going on at home too uh cressida
dick has said today that some but
probably not all of those 50 staff
members in downing street that have been
asked about the party sent
questionnaires may very well end up with
a fixed penalty notice you must be
worried
look uh beth i'm sure there will be
plenty to say about all that kind of
stuff in in due time but right now i
think people would understand that the
the focus of the uk government is on
bringing together our
our allies
in nato
and
making sure that we we stand shoulder to
shoulder but one thing that i think is
very important and matteos mentioned
this i think you picked it up in uh in
his remarks earlier on
we've got to have that automatic package
of sanctions ready to go and and he
singled out uh i thought uh
notably the nordstrom 2 pipeline that
colossal
gas pipeline now we all know how
difficult that is for some of our
friends and we all know that uh
particularly right now with the spike in
gas prices it will be tough uh to say no
to nordstrom 2. but i think it is
absolutely right i could just know that
we continue to make progress on that and
that is i think a very very important
question if we are to continue to bring
you back to the russian question if i
may 50 members of staff are being sent
questionnaires by the police
are you worried about that because the
public might be watching he said there
weren't any parties and now 50 members
of staff have been interviewed by the
police not worried about that beth i
will have plenty to say about that uh
when the process is coming i'm only
asking you i know you are president
i know you are beth i'll have plenty to
say about that uh when the process is
complete but what we're doing now is
showing uh that we are supporting our
polish friends the polls came to support
us in the second world war we stand side
by side with them today and actually one
one thing that i hope you picked up also
is the uh the way in which both poland
and the uk are offering uh direct uh
military support to uh our ukrainian
friends and we we both believe in a
sovereign uh independent uh
um
and
as you know
the uk has been supplying uh some
defensive weaponry in the form of
anti-tank um anti-tank missiles uh 2000
entertainment missiles we've been
training uh ukrainian troops
the uh the poles are also supplying uh
drones ammunition and so on now uh
that's as far as we can go
at the moment because
this is uh we are not ukraine is not
part of of nato but what we're sticking
up for
is the right of ukraine like any other
sovereign independent european country
to aspire to that okay i'm going to ask
you another question then have you
received a questionnaire yet from the
police
i'm going to tell you beth you will hear
all in due time on that matter so you
haven't
all you got you're going to hear all in
due time on that matter bet and i admire
your tenacity and trying to drag the
subject back but i'm focused here today
if i if i can and i've asked if i can
questions at the press conference about
that and i'm asking you questions about
that i don't know but i told you i'd be
very clear i will have more to say on
all that okay
something
on december the 1st you said in the
house of commons that all guidance was
followed completely in number 10 direct
quote do you now accept that you misled
parliament given that there are now 50
members of staff being investigated by
the police look beth i'm going to have
plenty to say about all that
when the process is complete and i think
it'd be wrong frankly to comment uh on
all of that until the process is i do
think people understand that beth but
what i think what i think it people also
want to know about is
is what we are doing to avert what could
be uh one of the worst crises military
humanitarian on our european continent
uh in decades i know
i've talked about sanctions i've talked
about the military assistance that we're
giving i've talked about all the ways
we're standing shoulder to shoulder with
our polish friends and
backing up uh our eastern european
friends let me say something finally
beth about diplomacy
and that is the
that's got to be the way forward there
has got to be room for a conversation
with the kremlin about what they are
doing it cannot be sensible for them
continually to threaten ukraine with 130
000 troops there has to be a way out of
this it will be a disaster for them it
will be disaster for russia it'd be
disaster for the world if they were to
invade there must be an off-ramp for
conversations about exactly what kind of
forced dispositions nato is going to
have in uh
in eastern europe and
transparency about that transparency
about missile placements there is a
conversation to be had but my final
point to you beth is that i think
today
10th february 2022
we stand on the edge of a precipice and
things are as dangerous as i've seen
them in europe for for a very very long
time it's up to
vladimir putin now to disengage and to
de-escalate and the way forward is
diplomacy thank you very much thank you
thank you
about john major prime minister because
john major said that you shredded
diplomacy so
i think you i think i think that that
well let me
sir john major he says that our uh our
reputation has been shredded this is a
this is him a speech in london he said
our reputation has been shredded uh by
what's been going on in number 10
internationally he said that you broke
lockdown laws dreamt up brazen excuses
and he says it was always the case that
a pm that breaks the law should resign
that's a former prime minister saying
that i'm going to have plenty to say
about all that in due course but if you
look at what the uk is doing to bring
the world together to if you talk to our
friends in in lithuania uh in ukraine
where i was uh the other week uh or here
today in poland you can see that
actually it is the united kingdom that
has been working for months
to warn people about what was happening
and uh i'm afraid we've we've been sadly
proved right in what we were saying it's
been the united kingdom that has been
working to bring countries together uh
not just in
the sanctions package that that we want
to see the very tough sanctions package
that we want to see but also in making
sure that we fortify nato's eastern
frontier in the way that we're doing and
that's why we're here today that's why
i'm very pleased to see uh four five
commando come in in the way they are to
back up all the other uk uh service men
and women here in berlin thank you very
much
okay thank you sir